So here's a little, tiny POMDP that I've
thought about in the past that I think
makes makes for good illustration.
So we've got four underlying states,
these four here,
the four circles, and
we've got two actions.
The actions essentially
move the agent left and
right along this kind of hallway
type thing, with some exceptions.
So from the green state,
any action just resets you randomly
to one of the blue states.
And otherwise,
things move left and right.
At the end of the hallways here, these
two end states, if you try to go right
when there's no more space to go,
you just stick where you were.
And if you try to go left when
there's no more space to go,
you stick where you were.
And just to ground it
the rest of the way out,
actions that take you to the green
state give you a reward of one.
So does that makes some sense to you?
Do you do follow how this would go?
>> I do, and I just realize,
if I don't know which blue state I'm in,
this is a scary,
scary little problem to try to solve.
>> Good, so that was the thing I
guess I neglected to point out.
I'm showing the observations in
this diagram with the colors.
So let me just number the states
just for ease of referring to them.
We've got three states, 1, 2, 3, and 4.
State 1 is blue, state 2 is blue,
state 4 is blue.
Based on the immediate
observation alone,
we don't know really where we are.
And we could be a place that's
to the right of the goal, so
we should go left to get reward.
Or we could be a place that's
to the left of the goal,
which means we're going to
go right to get reward.
And so we're kind of in a tricky spot.
>> Yeah, this is unfortunate.
You're trapped like a rat in a maze.
>> I see, I see.
Yeah, you're pointing out that, [LAUGH]
to you, this looks like a rat drawing,
but it really is not
supposed to be a rat.
This is not the nose.
This is not the tail.
It really is just transitions.
>> I think you doth protest too much.
[LAUGH]